en el vídeo anterior terminamos con el
león jadeando también conocido como león
jade y ccoo que se le llamó así por
hades el dios griego del inframundo
hermano mayor de zeus y es un buen
nombre para este periodo porque el
ambiente era terrible había lava por
todos lados y caían cosas del espacio
impactando en la tierra así que era un
ambiente muy inhóspito para la vida y
después aún cuando la tierra había
empezado a enfriarse incluso la corteza
se había solidificado un poco y las
colisiones empezaron a cesar conforme
pasaban millones de años después de que
díaz chocó con la tierra y se formó la
luna ocurrió algo conocido como
bombardeo intenso tardío así que
cualquiera que haya sido la primera
existencia de vida de la que descendemos
tuvo que surgir después del bombardeo
porque este fue un período en el que
muchísimo
cosas que venían del espacio golpeaban a
la tierra y los impactos eran tan
violentos que pudieron haber matado a
cualquier molécula u organismo primitivo
que haya existido antes de eso y la
razón por la que creemos que existió ese
bombardeo es porque urano y neptuno si
este es el sol y este es el cinturón de
asteroides al formarse el sistema solar
el cinturón quedó por fuera de la órbita
de los planetas rocosos que serían los
planetas internos mientras que las
órbitas de urano y neptuno se movieron
hacia el exterior y eso causó que
gravitacionalmente muchos de los
asteroides del cinturón se movieran
hacia el interior impactando a los
planetas internos entre ellos la tierra
y bueno el sol es amarillo o naranja no
se vayan a confundir con la tierra así
que todos esos asteroides
bien impactaron en la luna sobre todo
porque la luna no tiene una atmósfera
que pueda detener el impacto pero solo
hasta después del bombardeo intenso
tardío la tierra estuvo lista para la
vida se cree que la primera vida surgió
hace 3.8 a 4 mil millones de años
recuerde que por jica es decir mil
millones de años y cuando hablamos de la
vida en ese periodo no estamos hablando
de ardillas o de osos pandas en este
periodo sólo existían formas de vida muy
simples las procariotas procariotas pero
vamos a compararlas con las eucariotas
eucariotas las procariotas son
organismos unicelulares que no tienen un
núcleo definido tampoco tienen organelos
o celdas que hagan funciones específicas
como la mitocondria así que él
n está suelto procariotas significa
antes del núcleo mientras que las
eucariotas si tienen un núcleo donde se
encuentra el adn y también tienen otros
organelos como la mitocondria que es
como una procariotas adentro de otra
interactuando en una especie de
simbiosis lo que nos interesa por ahora
es que al hablar de la vida en este
periodo estamos hablando de las
procariotas incluso actualmente todavía
existen porque las bacterias y las
arqueas son ejemplos de procariotas para
entenderlo un poco mejor aquí tenemos el
árbol filogenético y este punto es el
ancestro que tienen en común las
procariotas y las eucariotas las
bacterias y arqueas son procariotas y
estas son las eucariotas entonces se
cree que el primer conjunto de
organismos vivos fue una especie de
moléculas que se
replicaron y con el tiempo lentamente
apareció una membrana y la estructura de
los organismos se fue organizando tal
vez el a rn fue la molécula que
originalmente se auto replicó
convirtiéndose en una forma de
transmitir la información de una
generación a la siguiente y aunque se
desconoce cómo fue la primera aparición
de la vida basados en los estudios
genéticos de las moléculas en los
organismos actuales se cree que ocurrió
algo como lo que tenemos en este árbol
que sería el primer ancestro y después
empieza la ramificación por lo que las
arqueas y las eucariotas tienen un
ancestro en común que es diferente al de
las bacterias por acá tenemos el ejemplo
de una bacteria esta es la coli
escherichia colli y es una forma de vida
procariotas
que las primeras formas de vida eran
anaerobias no necesitaban el oxígeno
incluso les resultaba tóxico así que las
primeras formas de vida no realizaban la
fotosíntesis probablemente obtenían su
energía de otras fuentes como por
ejemplo químicas porque recuerden que en
ese tiempo había un ambiente
extremadamente violento ahora si nos
adelantamos un poco al evento más
importante de la tierra
recuerden que estas son escalas de
tiempo enormes aquí estamos hablando de
800 millones de años y por ejemplo los
humanos y los chimpancés se separaron
hace 5 millones de años y la antigua
grecia existió hace 2500 años si
multiplicamos eso por 1000 obtenemos dos
mil quinientos millones de años pero
esto equivale a 800 millones de años
son períodos de tiempo enormes por eso
se les llama eones ahora la línea que
divide a leon hatiano del eón arcaico es
un poco difusa pero muchas personas la
fijan en aproximadamente 3.8 mil
millones de años donde se encontraron
las primeras rocas las rocas aparecieron
hace aproximadamente 3.8 mil millones de
años y ahí es en donde podemos marcar el
inicio del eón arcaico en este on hay
dos cosas importantes las rocas y el
surgimiento de la vida entonces si
estudiamos el eón arcaico tal vez puedan
pensar oh entonces la tierra ya era un
lugar más agradable pero en realidad no
lo era porque todavía no había oxígeno
en la atmósfera si estuviéramos en la
tierra
en ese tiempo veríamos algo como esto
cielo era rojizo por el nitrógeno metano
y dióxido de carbono además había un
montón de actividad volcánica
esta es una fotografía de estromatolitos
estromatolitos
que se formen a partir de las bacterias
en las partículas de sedimento y con el
tiempo se van acumulando pero el evento
más importante al menos en mi opinión es
que aproximadamente hace 3.5 mil
millones de años las procariotas
especialmente las bacterias
evolucionaron hasta captar la energía
del sol y así poder llevar a cabo la
fotosíntesis y lo más fascinante es que
no sólo pudieron usar la energía
directamente del sol sino que con eso
empezaron a producir oxígeno entonces
empieza la producción de oxígeno y al
principio el oxígeno fue producido por
las cianobacterias conocidas como algas
verdeazuladas pero no se pudo acumular
en la atmósfera porque había mucho
hierro disuelto en los océanos
y la única vida de la que podemos hablar
durante todos estos miles de millones de
años ocurrió en el océano además todavía
no existía la capa de ozono por lo que
la tierra recibía mucha radiación y el
suelo era un ambiente inhóspito para la
vida por eso toda la vida ocurría en el
océano entonces las primeras
producciones de oxígeno terminaron
formando enlaces con el hierro que había
en el océano y por eso no podía
acumularse en la atmósfera pero si
avanzamos en el tiempo una vez que todo
el hierro fue oxidado y el oxígeno
finalmente pudo ser liberado tuvo un
efecto catastrófico en la vida anaerobia
de ese período es chistoso porque fue
algo malo para ellos pero también era
algo necesario que tenía que ocurrir
para que nosotros pudiéramos existir así
que para nosotros fue muy bueno que las
no bacterias pudieran producir tanto
oxígeno para oxidar el hierro y con el
tiempo liberar un montón de oxígeno a la
atmósfera y aunque murieron muchísimas
de esas bacterias anaerobias aparecieron
los organismos que respiran aire pero
para que eso ocurriera todavía faltaban
muchos miles de años